hey guys pete here history is a form of
memory
but what does it mean to remember we
think naturally of our own past
our lives day by day and through them we
see the events of our time
we are black and white rich and poor
foreign-born
and domestic and yet if our past are
separate then aren't our history
separate too
ask yourself who writes the books who
chooses what we remember
and what gets forgotten so we have made
it to the finale of season four of fargo
it's a definitive ending to this chapter
of the story
i'm gonna recap what happened break it
down and at the end i'll tell you how i
felt about it
before we get started all of what i just
said should be setting off your natural
spoiler warnings
if not just to be clear this video will
include spoilers for the finale of
season four
if you haven't watched it yet then this
video won't be for you
and so now let's get into it the episode
opens with a montage we see all the
characters we've lost throughout
the season while they all didn't
necessarily strike a chord
seeing rabbi and dr senator certainly
did and the johnny cash playing in the
background
over the great-looking photography made
for a fine way to open things up
from there we find loy and abel talking
on a park bench
the same park bench where loy and
donatello fata met early in the season
we check in with josto who's drinking
heavily and you can't blame him
his brother just died his mom fairly
recently
and of course the season started with
the death of his father
and we also see that his lover orienta
mayflower is in fact in jail
over at the smutney's place we see loy's
oldest son lemuel handing over the keys
to the family
they're moving their things out they're
handing the business back over to the
family
and so we learned that ethel rita's
appeal to loy was successful
and that he is in fact a man of his word
his son says impressive on the way out
and ethel rita's mother dabrell says yes
she is
in their meeting loy returns donatello's
ring to abel
orienta is pleasantly surprised that
someone's paid her bail even though she
doesn't know who it is
we see her boss dr harvard talking at
the hospital
talking about how they had a murderer
right there under their roof
unfortunately for him he's attacked by
josto outside
he's thrown into the back of his car
with josto's would-be
father-in-law melvin the alderman he
takes them out in the middle of nowhere
he shoots them up inside the car and
then in a dramatic sequence
he flicks his cigarette burning the car
with their bodies in it that cuts to the
ending of loya
abel's meeting the canon leader asks him
if he wants the war to be over
and tells him to get his house in order
abel seems to be on board he tells him
i'll get back to you
and then he leaves and in the car we see
that the youngest father brother
zero has been returned to the family
zero leaves him with a smile they share
the smile
and again this sort of underlines that
loy isn't completely dishonorable
in a heavy duty scene with a lot of slow
motion
we watched loy stand at the window of
his hotel staring out
thinking about the situation we see leon
sneak in
he has a gun with a silencer he's about
to take him out
but before he can pull the trigger opel
creeps up and strangles him to death
i really enjoyed how loy never breaks
his stair out the window
the whole thing happens and he's still
in the same position he was in the
beginning of the scene
across town at spuds all the time where
dr senator was killed outside
we watched happy and his henchmen get
taken out it's a classic
mob land execution that looks pretty
great
with lloyd's threats neutralized we go
back to find josto
joe bulow tells them that they got
cannon it's over we won
this is exactly what he wanted to hear
so he's ready to go out and
celebrate but quickly figures out
something's wrong when he sees that abel
sitting on a chair with the rest of the
gang behind him
and orienta's at his side his concierie
tells him that he's accused of crimes
against the family
he accuses him with getting orienta to
kill his father
so that he could wear the crown and even
implies that he took out gaetano
josto tries to deny it and for what it's
worth he didn't realize that orrietta
was a serial killer
so he wasn't actually telling her to
kill his father
but that's how she interpreted it she
followed through with it
and she's happy to tell the rest of the
gangsters in the room that that's
exactly what happened
it turns out that she may be a serial
killer who likes to kill people but she
feels it's very important to be truthful
in certain situations josto tries to
cast doubt then he threatens abel saying
he's gonna get in touch with new york
that's when he finds out his fate is
sealed when abel
tells him that new york has already
approved the hit one more thing that we
get from this exchange
is that abel believes that the fada
family has had
problems because they've been run too
long as a family business
he says we live in the new world now we
need a new way
and of course this plants the seeds for
what we see with the kc mob in season
two
josto and orienta are taken to a freshly
dug hole in the ground with their name
on it
josto tries to find an angle to get his
way out of the situation
but other than making joe bulow laugh
with the question hasn't there already
been enough killing
his pleas go unanswered to add insult to
injury when asked if they have any final
requests
ori etta asked that they kill josto
first so she can watch
i thought this was a pretty good touch
he gets shot almost immediately after
and she looks really turned on by the
whole situation
we then see her looking at her own
reflection in the car and i like to
think that she's watching
so she can see her own death as well
either way she gets her bullet and
they're both left behind
with things settling down the cannon
family leaves the hotel and returns home
when he gets there the doors open and i
thought this played pretty well
too because we know zelmaire's out there
somewhere
so when he puts together the pieces that
his son has returned his son that he
thought was dead
it made for a pretty good reunion and it
was also nice to see that rabbit made it
as well he was right there on the bed
at this point it seems like loys won all
that's left to do is for him to go talk
to abel
and get back to business as usual
unfortunately
things don't go over as planned abel
tells him there's a few small
adjustments he had to write
down it turns out that it's not a few at
all
it actually amounts to lloyd losing half
of his business
he's justifiably angry but there's
really nothing he can do about it
abel justifies it saying it's part of
their new national plan
he says you two are a national outfit
yes
wait no you're one man in one city what
do they say
big fish small pond but we're the sea
the italian knows that he wants to kill
him but reinforces the fact that he has
no chance of taking back over the city
he leaves them with the idea of we're
not taking half we're leaving half
and loy knows that if he doesn't accept
the deal they'll kill him and find
somebody else who will
he goes back to his house he tells opal
to go home
he looks in the window he sees his happy
family and it's like he has this moment
of acceptance he lost this struggle for
power
the deck was stacked against him but
seeing his family happy
and knowing that they all made it out
seems to give him some peace
and it turns out to be well timed since
some mayor does show up
stabbing him several times and killing
him it seemed pretty inevitable that
she'd show up so it wasn't a big shock
but she does tell him as he's dying that
it was for swanny
so at the very least she got justice for
her dead partner
satchel caught a glimpse of her in the
window so he went outside
she drops the weapon and leaves and he
sees his father's last moments loy isn't
able to say anything to him so they just
shared the moment
and it does carry some additional weight
knowing that satchel had just lost
rabbi not that long ago and it was a
nice touch that he's pulled away from
reading dale carnegie's how to win
friends and influence people
which he first heard about in the barton
arms
the episode comes to a close with ethel
rita reading her history report
it ends with what i opened with who
chooses what we remember and what gets
forgotten we see her with her family and
then we see her sitting in a chair
with some suitcases and we see her get
up to leave
in a post finale interview noah hawley
says that it represents her leaving
her reward for surviving the story is
that she goes off and has an
unremarkably positive life
that was the worst thing she ever went
through in her life and her reward is
that like james baldwin
she's going to move to paris she's going
to become a writer
and she's going to prosper outside of
america she knows in that moment that
she can't prosper inside america
and she has the wherewithal to get out
the episode proper
ends there but we also get a mid-credit
scene
where it's confirmed that satchel does
grow up to be mike milligan
we see mike in the back seat with gail
kitchen driving
it's a scene right out of season two
where they're going down the road
the way it's cut we see that this is the
same road that satchel walked home on
and we see mike reloading the gun like
rabbi did and know now
that he has an origin story and in that
season 4 of fargo comes to an
end i think this finale is much like the
rest of the season
it had its moments it was a surprisingly
short episode
and that makes me question how much the
pandemic affected this season overall
the way that the middle of the season
was so strangely cut together and then
you have this finale that feels pretty
short
it seems like on some level they weren't
able to execute their idea completely
the music was great the cinematography
was great
some of these scenes really are dazzling
but it's funny because last week when i
did my recap
i said i might follow up with another
theories video and what i found in doing
that was that
one i watched the trailer and it pretty
much laid the whole thing out
two i went online looking and pretty
much everyone was saying the same thing
that i had thought
and three it almost came out exactly
that way
it really didn't turn out to be shocking
or exciting
it had some tension and there were times
when i wasn't sure where they were going
based on things that they had set up
earlier
but it just felt sort of adequate at the
end like an adequate conclusion
for a season that had some real problems
getting to the finish line
there's not much else i can say about it
it was enjoyable all the way through
i really enjoyed some of the characters
orienta rabbi
ethel rita deffy was fun dr senator had
a real presence
but it's not an example of fargo firing
on all cylinders
it sort of wasn't able to find its
balance for me it felt like a weird
situation where
it was too much and not enough at the
same time too many characters too many
stories
not enough oomph when they all came
together and it's kind of disappointing
because the ideas behind it and some of
the themes really are
interesting and it's a real shame if the
pandemic sort of threw things off the
tracks
and with that i'm gonna leave it there
let me know in the comments what you
think about this finale what you think
about this season
what is your ranking for the four
seasons of fargo at this point
are you still hoping to see a season
five and in what time period would you
like to see them land
in in that please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
thanks for following along with the
season with me and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon